it's your birthday Chris Brockman is it
not today is my birthday how are you
Chris Brockman today I am 28 for the
11th time ago Wow okay so you're feeling
like this day is not very special in a
way I can already hear that 30 yeah well
you know it's like you know it's not yet
40 which is a big one right as you know
and so you're just kind of in that
no-man's land of like am 39 well I still
wanted to make it special for you well I
thank you man and use some rich eyes and
show real estate to tell you how much
all of us here really appreciate you for
who you are and what makes you tick deep
down inside and get somebody who makes
you very happy okay more often than you
have felt in quite some time
okay and get that person to call in and
wish you a happy birthday
and he is the man who last season led
Syracuse football to their first ten win
season since 2001
let's welcome Dino Babers to the Rich
Eisen show how are you coach rich are
you doing more importantly Chris happy
birthday of you coach papers today to
you that can't be birthday dear Chris
happy birthday you with whose house is
this
that's amazing
coach how you doing thank you so much
for calling in no I'll tell you what
when you have a great friend like rich
I mean how he just put it in a way that
there was no way that I could not be
here a part of you on this special day
you know that's phenomenal
my god you're like coach you have no
idea how you make this man so happy you
make him
more more happy than he's felt on many
many Saturday's in a long time so I mean
I hope financially he was rewarded
between you and me and not the IRS I
have been very happy coach pavers thank
you so much well I'm sure coach you hear
that's a lot right I'm sure you must
hear this a lot from the Syracuse alums
what you have been able to to do up
there and
in New York State I tell you what I hear
a lot from I hear a lot we have a lot of
guys that are in the National Football
League and I don't know if this is to be
true because I got cut I never got an
opportunity to go up there but there's
some kind of unwritten rule that you you
have to you have to back your team and
more than just face when they play
somebody during the weekend I've heard
from a lot of alumnus that you know they
did very well last year like Chris was
stating I mean not just financially
coach I think more importantly I'm sure
I speak for all the alumni you brought
the pride back we were at the bottom of
the college football
well the basement so to speak for a long
time and it was kind of a bummer to be a
Syracuse football fan just to see the
basketball how have their success and go
to Final Fours and not being able to
feel that and see that on the football
field not being able to see the Carrier
Dome packed with 50,000 strong and the
loud house and then last year you
brought that back so from all of the
alumni thank you so much we appreciate
it it's more than just myself I'll tell
you what the 2018 class the seniors were
amazing and and they really did will
this thing to happen and it may have
happened one year before it should have
happened but there was no doubt there
was no way that they were going to go
out and let someone else get the credit
I think the big work now is to make sure
that we can make sure that 2019 was as
good as 2018 and there's no guarantee
every season is different but we're
really working hard to see if we can
keep the trend going so to speak yeah I
mean it started in 2017 with the huge
home win over Clemson the fans storming
the field that was something we did my
freshman year actually 1998 we storm the
field against Virginia Tech when Donovan
dad threw a game-winning touchdown pass
and to see the students do that again in
2017 brought back all of those memories
and then last year to almost do it again
at Clemson but to have a ten win season
to win a bowl game and now we're not
sneaking up on anybody and now that's
true I saw a coach
the recent ACCC media gathering that you
got a couple first-place votes I saw
that tell you what it must have been
some guys that there's new drugs going
around town okay I'm not quite sure but
no it was nice to get some first-place
votes it was it was really flattering
but you know we all understand that that
team that didn't lose a game in 2018 is
really really good and we'll have our
hands full on homecoming we play the
opener in the ACC well I mean how how
have you been able to do this I mean how
does one come into a program that as
crisp as an alum pointed out was was
laying a little bit low and do what you
have done I mean can you walk me through
what the plan was and how you've been
able to put it in into practice here
Chris 39:39 yeah I tell you what I'm
just believing everything happy birthday
to the 39 year old I'll tell you what
you are what you said you know I don't
know I don't know the answer to that I
really don't I really don't rich I think
what it is is I think before you start
to win as a team that you got to get
other people around you to believe that
you're winning that you're going to win
and that starts with the administration
the trainers the food people when you
start treating people like winners they
start acting like it and I think that's
the biggest thing and turning around
teams that are having success and teams
that are not having success is to get
the community and the administration to
see the light at the end of the tunnel
even though it's a very very dim light
at the time and to work towards that
light in and when they start treating
you the right way and the kids start
acting the right way normally normally
good things start to happen and I think
that was the big thing here at Syracuse
University
well coach appreciate you doing this
Chris is there a birthday wish that you
want to have the coach potentially grant
here I mean this is a wash you know how
I've been back to campus in a long time
but I will be there on September 14th
for the Clemson game so let's say let's
bring over w but let's bring home a
great effort and keep making us proud
coach really appreciative of you Chris I
got one for you you do realize was the
greatest orange I won't can't say the
last part because you know they changed
our lat our tag name I know the greatest
orange ever was wore the Jersey 39 you
know that don't you
the great Walter Reyes of course well
that's true that's true but also Larry
Csonka oh you're right single bond what
Larry did in the pros right that hasn't
been broken right okay let me fill you
in Larry Csonka was a member of the
Miami Dolphin football team on the
season rant entirely an NFL without
losing a game and winning the Super Bowl
they're the only NFL team to ever go
undefeated along with winning the Super
Bowl I'm a Patriots fan so I know that
too well oh boy any worse so where are
we going with this only thing I'm going
with it is Larry Csonka the Syracuse guy
chris is a Syracuse guy chris is 39
Larry Csonka was undefeated with the
with the dollars you know good things
could be happening around here thank you
for calling in coach really appreciate
it thanks for you got it appreciate you
that's Dino Babers sir Q's head coach
that was awesome thanks reg appreciate
that happy birthday Chris thank you and
here you thought fired up here you
thought I was gonna pull your pants down
going yard have a Yankee Colin how do I
handle that Mike he thought I wasn't
gonna go warm and fuzzy rich is a warm
and fuzzy guy down inside it's warm and
fuzzy when the cameras aren't on
happy birthday man that was awesome it
was really cool about four more of the
Rich Eisen show tune
- audience Channel 239 on DirecTV for
free on BR live or download the Rich
Eisen show app